Olha só, nem todo jejum ativa autofagia.
E a ciência já deixou isso bem claro. Se
você tá fazendo um jejum intermitente,
achando que tá bafando, automaticamente
tá ativando esse processo de limpeza
celular. Eu tenho uma notícia
importante. Pode ser que você esteja se
esforçando à toa. Um estudo publicado na
Nature Cell Biology em 2024 pelo grupo
do professor Frank Made, um dos maiores
pesquisadores de longevidade do mundo,
descobriu que existe um elemento
essencial, um gatilho bioquímico, sem
qual o jejum simplesmente não dispara a
autofagia. E hoje eu vou te mostrar
exatamente o que que a ciência mais
recente diz sobre como ativar autofagia
de verdade. Quais são os erros que a
maioria comete e o que você pode fazer
para garantir que esse mecanismo de
rejuvenescimento celular esteja
funcionando no seu corpo.
Antes de mais nada, vamos entender o que
que é autofagia sem aquela explicação
superficial de sempre. Autofagia
significa literalmente comer a si mesmo
do grego autoefagia,
mas isso não é nada destrutivo. Na
verdade é o sistema de reciclagem mais
sofisticado que existe na natureza.
Quando a autofagia está ativa, suas
células identificam componentes
danificados, proteínas mal dobradas,
mitocôndrias disfuncionais e as
encapsulam em estruturas chamadas
autofagossomos.
Esses tais de autofagossomos,
então, se fundem, se juntam com os
lisossomos, que são como centros de
reciclagem celular, onde tudo é quebrado
e reaproveitado. É como se a célula te
fizesse uma faxina geral, jogando fora o
que não serve mais e usando as peças
para construir componentes novos. E por
que que isso importa tanto para você?
Porque quando esse processo falha, as
células acumulam lixo. Esse acúmulo está
diretamente relacionado ao
envelhecimento acelerado, doenças
neurodegenerativas como Alzheimer e
Parxon, problemas cardiovasculares,
câncer e praticamente toda a doença
crônica que você possa imaginar. A
autofagia é tão importante que o
pesquisador japonês Yoshinori Ozumi
ganhou o prêmio Nobel de Medicina em
2016, justamente por desvendar os
mecanismos. Agora vem a parte que pouca
gente entende direito. A autofagia não
funciona como interruptor, liga e
desliga. Ela é controlada por uma
balança molecular entre duas proteínas
principais, a MPK em TOR. A MPK é como
sensor de energia baixa da célula.
Quando você está em jejum, quando você
faz exercício intenso, quando as
reservas de energia caem, a MPK é
ativada e ela diz pra célula: "Olha,
estamos em modo economia.
Vamos reciclar o que temos. Já a emitor
é o oposto. Ela é ativada quando a
abundância, especialmente de aminoácidos
e glicose. A Emitor diz pra célula:
"Temos recursos, vamos crescer, vamos
construir." O problema é que a mitor
cronicamente aumentada, exageradamente
aumentada, que é o que acontece quando
você come o tempo todo, isso vai inibir
completamente a autofagia. E aqui entra
descoberta bombástica de 2024 que eu
mencionei no começo. O grupo do
professor Madeu na Austria descobriu que
o jejum por si só não é o suficiente.
Eles demonstraram que quando você jeja,
o seu corpo aumenta a produção de uma
substância chamada espermidina.
Essa espermidina é absolutamente
essencial. Eu já falei ela em vídeo
recente que fez muito sucesso.
Ela é importante para que a cascata
autofágica aconteça. Quando eles
bloquearam a síntese de espermidina em
animais em jejum, sabe o que aconteceu?
A autofagia não foi ativada. Zero. Nem
nos ratos, nem nas moscas, nem nas
leveduras. O jejum sozinho não fez nada.
Isso foi publicado na Nature Cell
Biology, uma das revistas mais
prestigiadas do mundo. Aliás, eu fiz um
vídeo detalhando especificamente essa
molécula, a espermidina, mostrando como
ela pode ativar a autofagia e até melhor
que o jejum em certas situações. Fica de
sugestão para você assistir depois. E
mais, eles fizeram estudos em humanos
também. Voluntários que fizeram o jejum
prolongado tiveram aumento nos níveis de
permidina no sangue. E esse aumento foi
correlacionado com ativação de
marcadores de autofagia. Ou seja, a
espermidina funciona como mensageiro
molecular que traduz o sinal de jejum em
ativação autofágica real. Isso explica
porque algumas pessoas fazem jejum e tem
resultados incríveis, enquanto outras
fazem o mesmo protocolo, não sentem
porcaria nenhuma. Se a capacidade do seu
corpo de produzir espermidina estiver
comprometida, seja por idade, por
deficiências nutricionais, por questões
genéticas, o jejum pode não estar
fazendo o que você pensa que tá fazendo.
E quanto tempo de jejum é necessário
para ativar essa tal de autofagia? Essa
é uma das perguntas que eu mais recebo e
a resposta honesta é: depende. Existe
até um ensaio clínico registrado no
clinical trials gov especificamente
desenhado para responder essa pergunta
em humanos. Os dados preliminares
sugerem que a autofagia começa a ser
detectável em células do sangue
periférico após 24 a 48 horas de jejum
em pessoas saudáveis. Mas há muita
variação individual. O Instituto Piloto
que foi publicado na Goscience em 2025
testou a dieta que mimetiza o jejum,
aquela desenvolvida pelo professor
Walter Longo e mediu marcadores de
autofagia em células humanas. O
resultado foi interessante, houve
ativação, mas foi modesta e dependeu
muito da formulação específica da dieta.
Ou seja, não é só sobre não comer, é
sobre criar as condições metabólicas
certas. Outro estudo publicado em
dezembro de 24, um ensaio randomizado
cruzado em humanos, mostrou que cobinar
exercício que depleta glicogênio com
jejum prolongado teve efeito superior na
ativação de marcadores de saúde celular
comparado ao jejum sozinho. Isso faz
todo sentido quando você entende
bioquímica. O exercício ativa a MPK,
depleta as reservas de energia e prepara
o terreno para que o jejum subsequente
seja muito mais efetivo. E tem mais uma
coisa que a pesquisa recente está
mostrando, a ativação cíclica é melhor
que constante. Alguns pesquisadores
estavam tentando manter a autofagia
ativada o tempo todo, pensando que tava
abafando, que mais seria melhor. Mas o
corpo dá um jeito, se adapta. Se você
está em jejum crônico, se você tá sempre
em recessão calórica severa, os
mecanismos de autofagia podem
dessensibilizar. Então a abordagem mais
inteligente parece ser ciclar, períodos
de ativação seguidos por período de
alimentação adequada. É como treino na
academia, você não treina o mesmo
músculo todos os dias e nem do mesmo
jeito sempre. Você estressa, recupera,
estressa, recupera. E os ativadores
farmacológicos naturais?
Existem compostos que mimetizam os
efeitos do jejum na autofagia. A
rapamicina, que inibe diretamente mitor
é usado em pesquisa e tem dados
impressionantes de extensão de vida em
animais, mas tem efeitos colaterais
importantes, incluindo imunospressão.
A metiformina, aquele medicamento para
diabetes, também ativa MPK e promove
autofagia. Existem estudos mostrando
melhora cognitiva em animais idosos
tratados cometiformina, com redução da
inflamação no cérebro e aumento de
autofagia no hipocampo. Entre os
compostos naturais, além da espermidina,
temos o resveratrol encontrado no vinho
tinto e nas uvas escuras que ativa a
cirtuína, as proteínas que trabalham
junto com a impecá para promover a
autofagia. e a curcumina do açafrão da
terra, o sufano do brócolis, o galato de
pigalato catequino do chá verde, todos
eles são excelentes. Esses compostos têm
mecanismos que de uma forma ou de outra
vão favorecer a balança pro laudo da
tofagia.
Agora, qual que é o erro mais comum que
eu vejo? As pessoas acham que fazer uma
janela de alimentação 16x8, aquele jejum
intermitente clássico, já é suficiente
para ter todos os benefícios da
autofagia? Infelizmente não. Olha, pode
ser até que seja, mas também pode ser
que não seja. 16 horas pode não ser
suficiente para você, especialmente se
você está em resistência única, se sua
última refeição foi pesada, por exemplo,
em carboidratos, ou se você não está
dormindo bem, ou se você está
estressado. Todos esses fatores afetam a
ativação de MPK e a inibição da emitor.
Autofagia não é sobre seguir uma rça de
bolo, é sobre entender os princípios,
adaptar pra sua realidade. Se você quer
maximizar sua chance de ativar esse
mecanismo de rejuvenecimento celular,
considere jejuns mais longos de maneira
ocasional, 24, 36 até 48 horas, sempre
com acompanhamento se você tiver
condições de saúde. exercício antes ou
durante o jejum, especialmente treinos
que depletam o glicogênio, alimentação
rica em composto que fornece permidina.
É o caso do queijo bem fermentado,
cogumelos, leguminosas e ciclar, não é
fazer sempre a mesma coisa. E se você
quer ficar no superficial, pode sair
agora. Mas se você quer a informação
completa, precisa saber que aqui no
YouTube eu tenho limitações. Eu não
posso detalhar protocolo de jejum de 72
horas, doses terapêuticas permidina,
combinações específicas para doenças
neurodegenerativas.
Na comunidade fechada é diferente. Lá eu
compartilho os protocolos exatos que eu
uso na clínica com dosagens precisas,
time de exercício, combinações que
potencializam resultados, lives semanais
para responder as dúvidas, PDF com 47
protocolos, temos o grupo maravilhoso no
WhatsApp que troca ideia todo dia. Se
você quer a visão funcional sem filtro,
clique em seja membro. No nível dois,
vamos ainda mais fundo. Decamos artigos
em live de 2 horas, como é o caso do
artigo do Madeu que eu comentei aqui
sobre Medina, controvérsias que ninguém
toca e seu nome será mencionado nos
vídeos como parte dessa comunidade.
Poucos têm essa coragem, você tem? E já
que estamos falando de jejum e
autofagia, você precisa entender que a
autofagia não é o único efeito do jejum
no seu corpo. Existe um impacto direto
no seu intestino que pode ser positivo
ou negativo, dependendo de como você
conduz o processo. Então esse é um ponto
que muita gente ignora. Então, assista
esse vídeo aqui sobre a verdade chocante
do jejum intermitente e o intestino que
vai complementar perfeitamente o que
você aprendeu hoje. Agradecimentos
especiais de coração aos nossos membros
queridos do Estudos Avançados da
comunidade fechada do YouTube. Começando
pelos novos membros que entraram
recentemente, Luciano Silva Paurinelli,
Luciano Elias, Lê Trigono, Juliana
Pontes, Carlos Rovi, Odonor Pinheiro,
Cíntia de Assis Oliveira, Jorge Cabral e
Fernando Machado. Sejam muito
bem-vindos. Agradeço também aos membros
que fizeram upgrade para os estudos
avançados. Irma, Iana, Antônio Renato,
Adriane, Dra. Paulo Rodrigues, José
Fortunato Murtinho, Souciol, Cristina
Carol, Romana Moraril, Estela Mari
Silva, Elô Terapias, Luís Anselmo, muito
obrigado pela confiança em elevar o
nível de participação. Um abraço
especial aos membros que retornaram à
comunidade, Alex Caldas, Marcelo
Pimentel e Cláudio Leitão. Que bom ter
vocês de volta. Eu quero fazer um
reconhecimento especial aos membros mais
fiéis. Estela Mares com incríveis 56
meses de fidelidade. Dra. Ana Paula com
44 meses de participação, Marcelo
Pimentel com 23 meses e Antônio Renato
com 21 meses de história conosco. A
todos vocês eu agradeço de coração pelo
apoio prestado. você fazem a diferença
nessa comunidade.